las vegas raiders kicking off their
season yeah they're going to play
baltimore over at allegion stadium
monday night of course you'll need a
ticket to get inside but you're also
going to need the coronavirus vaccine
right you do a new vaccine screening
option could make the whole process a
lot smoother that's the hope anyway
hector mejia joining us live this
morning from allegiant stadium with all
those details hector good morning
good morning guys and yeah we talked
with fans and not everyone is on board
with this new vaccine requirement at
raiders games this weekend though the
team will be offering alternate
screening at those white tents you see
out there that is parking lot b in front
of the stadium right along hacienda and
that is meant to make things run a
little easier a lot smoother for those
trying to head in through the front
doors
if you're partially vaccinated or have a
shot from another country the alternate
screening will be open ahead of the game
to save time and stress fans can also
get the covet shot on site which some
hope could work toward increasing our
numbers statewide i'm sure you can have
about 20 percent of those say hey you
know what i don't pay all this money i
already came here i can't get my tickets
back i'm going to get vaccinated anyway
i just don't feel it's fair because it's
so late in the season and people have
already purchased their tickets the
raiders are using the clear app to check
fans proof of vaccination status they're
encouraging everyone to download the app
at least 24 hours in advance and upload
their information which will be good for
the rest of the season
back out here you're taking a live look
at the clear app on this
ipad here uh once you download your
information as you just heard it'll be
good for the rest of the season that's
what you will present at the front door
but that is only for those who are fully
vaccinated in ages 14 and over those who
are partially vaccinated will have to
use the alternate screening that we
mentioned that is set up over there
across the street at the parking lot
reporting live outside allegion stadium
hector mejia 8 news now